another coffee here [ __ ] coming right up
Virgil Hey Tiana morning Georgia
[Music]
Disney directors and animators love to
hide Easter eggs and links to their
other movies and we love to spot them
here our tendency connections in The
Princess and the Frog that you might
have missed
keep watching to the end to discover
which character appears in the intro
sequence for many Walt Disney Pictures
also do a tip of the hat from dr. Vasily
a King Triton float Ron Clements and
John Musker directed The Princess and
the Frog and they also directed The
Little Mermaid so it makes sense that
they had some Easter eggs relating to
the 1989 movie in The Princess and the
Frog - like including Ariel's father
King Triton on a Mardi Gras float during
a parade want to know another fun fact
about this scene the directors also
included themselves in it in animated
form they're dressed in fish costumes
tossing bead necklaces called throws to
the crowd look further to the left and
you'll see Bruce W Smith - dressed in a
costume with a seashell on his head he
was the lead character animator for dr.
facili a magic carpet during the opening
credits of The Princess and the Frog we
see a busy street scene the people of
New Orleans are going about their
business look up at the balcony in the
top right corner of the screen and
you'll see a woman with her laundry
hanging out to dry
she's shaking out something pretty
special over the railings - it's the
magic carpet from Aladdin it's got that
blue background pattern border and
detailed centers it's even got the gold
tassels on each corner the magic carpets
cameo isn't surprising after all Ron
Clements and John Musker directed
Aladdin to genies lamp the directors
also included another Aladdin themed
Easter egg in The Princess and the Frog
and that's the genies lamp this little
nugget turns up during Mama Odie song
dig a little deeper Mama Odie is
throwing various items out of an old
trunk a seashell gets caught in her pet
snake juice mouth and the lamp goes
flying past it's not just any old lamp
as it has these same exact markings and
shape as the genies Lane
in Aladdin animal canes sticking with
Mama Odie and juju they also have a
moment that calls to mind the 1951
animated movie Alice in Wonderland Baba
Odie straightens her pet snake out into
a rod to use it as a cane to help her
find her way around she eventually
smashes his head into a bell by accident
and juju returns to his coiled posture
this is so reminiscent of the Queen of
Hearts playing croquet in Alice and
wonderland she picks out a flamingo and
straightens its neck to use it as a
croquet mallet poor flamingo Lewis and
madam MIM Mama Odie she the voodoo queen
of the bayou
when Lewis the alligator tells Naveen
and Tiana about mama
Odie's magic and spells he links back to
the 1963 movie the sword in the stone
when he mentions mama Odie's voodoo he
grabbed some Bayou moss from up above
and holds it over his head like pigtails
with his freaky face poking out he's
totally recreating a scene from the
sword in the stone did you know I can
make the shot ugly yet would be some
trick want to bet boom a 1 1 3 when we
see Tiana catching a trolley to her
second job it has the number 8 1 1 3 on
the front this pops up in lots of Disney
and Pixar movies and it's nostalgic nod
back to the animators classroom days the
majority of Disney and Pixar animators
spent time in Cal arts classroom a 113
this is where they learned character
animation and design there's another fun
Easter egg on the trolley or should we
say in the trolley it's conducted by the
movie screenwriter Rob Edwards Jack
Skellington dr. facili a shadow demons
are scary enough in their own right but
when you throw a recognizable spooky
character into the mix they get even
freakier we're talking about none other
than the patron spirit of Halloween
himself Jack Skellington the protagonist
of Tim Burton's 1993 Disney movie The
Nightmare Before Christmas would fit
right in with that scary crowd when dr.
facili a summons a whole group of his
friends from the other side one of them
looks Cara Lee familiar those large
oval-shaped eyes and tall skinny frame
definitely look like they belong to the
pumpkin king of Halloween town
but when Tiana transforms into a frog
all
eyes are on her surprising new form so
it's not surprising that most viewers
will miss the subtle nod to two other
Disney Princesses during the scene look
real close at the spines of the books on
the shelf in Charlotte's room you'll
notice that one is Rapunzel and another
is the Little Mermaid it's not
surprising Charlotte owns them after all
she's obsessed with becoming a princess
but why did the directors choose those
two titles specifically we already know
that the directors also worked on the
Little Mermaid and Rapunzel was the
working title for the next Disney
feature films
tangled firefly stars did you know the
idea of stars being fireflies relates
back to the 1994 film The Lion King
there's a scene where Pumbaa Timon and
Simba contemplate the night sky Timon
believes the stars are fireflies that
got stuck up there in that big bluish
black thing I always millions of miles
away and Simba says they're the great
kings of the past watching over us Ray's
fate seems to support Simba's theory and
it relates to another Disney movie as
we're about to discover second star to
the right when ray passes it's one of
the saddest scenes in the whole movie
but it's followed by a wonderful moment
when his grieving friends look up into
the night sky they see a second star
appear alongside Ray's longtime love
Evangeline what makes this moment even
more special is its secret link to
another Disney movie take a closer look
at the Stars
ray and Evangeline remind you of
anything it looked just like the second
star to the right image in the 1953
movie Peter Pan that's the entrance to
Neverland we also see these two stars at
the beginning of the Walt Disney
Pictures intro in mini Disney movies
that's a pretty sweet position for array
in Evangeline to occupy which of these
Disney connections did you spot in The
Princess and the Frog and which is your
favorite be sure to let us know in the
comments and that's a wrap please give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel for more great videos
like this one thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]